rapper Kanye West what did something
kind of amazing on Twitter today and
articulated or appear to articulate his
support for President Trump one of his
tweets written he's still tweeting right
now but one read this way you don't have
to agree with Trump but the mob cannot
make me not love him
we are both dragon energy he is my
brother I love everyone I don't agree
with everything anyone does that's what
makes us individuals and we have a right
to independent thought well the
president respond to this by tweeting
Thank You Kanye oh very cool
after the tweets West's Twitter
following which was enormous plunged I
think this is right by more than 9
million followers what do we make of all
of this Jason Whitlock is an anchor with
Fox Sports 1 and he joins us tonight so
know what I mean I'm not sure I
understand exactly what's going on here
it seems maybe Kanye West decided that
he's allowed as a citizen of a free
country to say exactly what he wants to
say what what's your read on this what
does this mean why did he write this
well I think he wrote it because it's
what he authenticated to having more
open mind about politics and to be less
demonizing of people we disagree with
and understand that we're all flawed our
president is flawed but that doesn't
mean we should it's an effective
strategy to write that person off or to
write that side of politics off and so I
just think Kanye's being true to himself
and trying to open African Americans
mind that in all things competition is
good
my background is sports and competition
is what takes you to a higher level
there's no competition for the black
vote right now and there has been none
for 50 or 60 years I think we should
look around at other ethnic groups and
other groups of people they make people
compete for their votes and politics
tend to help them and move them forward
while we're not experiencing the same
thing right
well groups any group that feels under
attack tends to kind of retreat into a
defensive posture and and you see this
in not just
african-american learners but other
groups to this exact same phenomenon but
I totally agree it's not helpful what I
mean what's the risk that he runs and
sang this it seems like kind of even for
a famous guy like Kanye West it seems
like kind of a fraught position to take
I mean is he not gonna be punished for
this can you say this he's certainly
gonna be punished over social media
and it does not surprise me that he's
lost a bunch of Twitter followers or IG
followers or social media followers
because much of social media is rigged
to support far left-wing thought and if
you stray particularly as an African
American from the talking points that
the left-wing far left wing side wants
you to they're going to extract that a
penalty for you having thoughts that
they haven't approved again Kanye's a
free thinker he always has been his
music has always been open to a lot of
different interpretation and just ideas
I think he's just being consistent and
true to himself and again trying to
inspire people so really quickly we're
hearing from Twitter that he actually
didn't lose 9 million followers with
something which apparently I don't
understand it but quickly you're hearing
people say well he must have a mental
illness what do you think of that
explanation I think it's ridiculous and
I think it again goes to us as African
Americans and social media has so
convinced us that liberal means Pro
black and conservative means anti black
that that's how we interpret things oh
my god Kanye has said things that are
conservative or any conservative values
he expressed support for Candace Owens
over social media and and we've been
trained to anything conservative that
means anti black and again if we just
looked critically and unjust really
understood our history that's just not
the case a lot of our values are
conservative a lot of the people in our
community that have made great strides
and had one Luther King very
conservative values the entire movement
was very conservative but somehow we've
changed that and you would think it was
the most far left-wing movement in the
world and that's how we got here
through liberalism and again I'm not a
political part or partisan I don't
participate in politics I'm a journalist
and I'm an observer observing us say
speaking as a journalist not as an
African American our strategy is flawed
by just giving away our allegiance to
one side and I think Kanye out of
concern for african-americans is trying
to say yeah this is a flawed strategy
that is actually making us back go
backwards rather than forward it's
pretty bold move I would say Jason thank
you